this is a different interpretation in
the sense that it's based very closely
on Raj odd Kipling's book which he wrote
in 1894 so it is very much a story about
Mowgli's central journey his journey of
self-discovery he is a boy that is an
orphaned child that has grown up with
Wolves believes himself to be a wolf
until he reaches a moment in his
adolescence where he is becomes
painfully aware that the rest of the
journey is about him assimilating into
the world of man where he also finds
both good and bad so it's a very Mowgli
centric journey but it's also
historically placed and contextualized
in a India of the turn of the century
when the book was written the huge
challenge on this movie was really how
to make talking animals believable I
mean we've seen lots of talking animals
in movies and you can make them look
great and you can make them look as if
they're talking but actually can you
make them feel as if they're really
emotionally connecting with Mowgli and
that was the big challenge and so for
that we went to great lengths using
performance capture technology tom
hollander is incredible as tabacky the
hyena he is such a wicked sense of humor
Cate Blanchett's Python car to bring a
Python to life and to really connect
with that because they have such dead
eyes in real life and what cater
standards extrordinary she becomes this
Prophet character but there are many
many great performances from all of our
cars Rowan chant who plays Mowgli is a
real revelation and his story of
self-discovery of learning who he is in
both worlds is amazing you really go
through it with Mowgli and I think it
should be emotionally engaging and you
know at times it'll make you feel sorry
for him it'll make you feel angry on his
behalf you through his eyes will really
hopefully feel what he's going through
[Music]